foreign
that's the White House Howard hunt
Howard the president asked for a real
son of a to handle this Pentagon
leak what do you need I want you to meet
Gordon Liddy toughest guy I know to hold
his hand in the flame of the candle I do
not Bend and I do not break what's the
trick there's a one gets third degree
burns every time please stop
you now work for the committee to
reelect the president
your new mission is to make sure he wins
this election we'll intercept
confidential information of the radical
left
what's the plan we're going to hit the
DNC at the Watergate Howard that is the
stupidest thing I've ever heard
[Music]
strike tonight
these are the wrong doors what he has
the wrong tools
[Music]
and we walk straight in the front door
Bolt
boots
somebody needs to clean this mess up you
want us to break in a fourth time wait
what do you mean a fourth time
nothing spy talk
how does it work there's a chance I'd be
going to prison
wait what
I really hope you understand the scope
the scale of this thing you tell
spineless two-faced politicians loyalty
is a two-way street
[Applause]
did you just use the fun family outing
to cover up some spy fish
I'm not a bunch of bulls why are you
shredding money we're Patriots acting in
the country's best interests
interest
family
[Music]
they are trying to break us
president is a good man
between you and me I worry about some of
the people with whom he surrounds
himself
plumbers who fix leaks
[Music]